we're better ready to pick back up on
where the question is taking us so it
says we did Part B just now it says Part
C when does it return to the origin what
is its velocity then and in which
direction is it accelerating so this is
kind of like a triple barreled question
right the first thing they're asking is
when does it return to the origin
what is its velocity at that point and
then in which direction is it
accelerating so this is in our X
equation our DX on DT equation X dot if
you like and d squared X on DT squared
or X double dot equation acceleration
alright so one step at a time when is a
return to the origin well like I've been
doing I'm just going to clear this
working off so that I can look at the
graph clearly without any other stuff we
have as you can already see sort of
already answered this question right it
returns to the origin down here this is
that spot where and another graph is
slightly off but I think that's just a
printing error type of graphical thing
you can see it's sort of heads in a
positive direction then heads in the
negative direction it comes all the way
back at time nine right so I can say
let's write down Part C here that's C
after nine seconds that is when the
particle has completed the same amount
of distance in the positive direction as
it has in the negative direction so
that's why you're back at the origin
which is where you started particles of
course don't have to start at the origin
you could start your particle anywhere
you like like here or here but in this
case the particle does start there which
is why they say return to the origin so
after nine seconds particle returns to
the origin and then the next two
questions within Part C are about the
velocity and acceleration now like I
mentioned before we've already answered
some of this right because we identified
time nine as one of our stationary
points here it is right here the
particles stationary at three and nine
so what is its velocity its velocity is
zero so at this time velocity is zero
and because my units are meters and
I will include them in my answer floss
is 0 meters per second and then I have
to say the direction of the acceleration
now this is this is tricky we need to
think about this for a second right um
acceleration what does that come from
this is the second derivative of the
displacement right you start with this
placement first derivative takes two -
velocity second area till it takes you
to acceleration and so what that means
is if I'm talking about the second
derivative I'm really thinking about
concavity that's what the second
derivative tells us when we think about
graphing techniques right
so in which direction is accelerating is
another way of saying or I could reword
that as which direction is the concavity
facing in if you're concave in the
positive direction then you're
accelerating in the positive direction
and if you're concave in the negative
direction you're accelerating in a
negative direction okay so which one is
it when you have a look at this time
here that I've identified at time 9 um
clearly this section of the graph that's
highlighted in the right color this
whole section of the graph here it's
concave up right all of these sections
here you can imagine them like a cup
that's holding water right so even
though I don't have an equation for
acceleration I can see from the graph I
can interpret visually that it's concave
up so therefore concave up I should take
concave in the positive direction
because as you can see over here if I
come back to this graph if I put all
that same information over here there's
my point returned to the origin he is
the concavity this graph over here more
accurately represents the left rightness
of the situation so it's concave right
as you can see okay so therefore I am
accelerating in the rightward direction
so I'm gonna write that down in my
answer here this time velocity zero
meters per second and acceleration is to
the right
which by the way it makes sense because
if you have a look at this graph you can
see sort of carrying on over here right
the graph gets faster and faster moving
in that rightward direction I'm
represented by the steepness of the
graph over here in the original so
therefore you can say more and more
acceleration just faster and faster and
faster I'm over there in that rightward
direction okay so that was part C we're
almost the halfway max so this next
question says when is its acceleration
zero where is it then and in what
direction is it moving so another
triple-barreled question here so you can
see here I'm being asked when another
time where is it
so that's a displacement question and
then in what direction is it moving
that's a velocity question okay
so when is its acceleration zero well
I'm going to kind of pick up where we
were thinking about on our previous
question in acceleration can be found by
thinking about concavity okay so if
concavity is the easiest way to look for
an even the next question Part II kind
of anticipates this right I can look for
concavity by finding the part of the
graph that doesn't have any concavity or
has a concavity of zero right it's not
concave up it's not concave down or
positive or negative it would look like
a straight line essentially okay so when
is its acceleration zero when you have a
look here you can see I've already
highlighted part of the graph which is
concave up okay and you can see there is
clearly a point over here where it's
concave down right
this part's concave down and I'm kind of
leaning into the next question already
but the reason why I'm highlighting this
is because and even the graph itself
gives you some helpful information to
identify this it must be a switchover
point between at least on this graph
because it's continuous there must be a
switchover point between the concave
negative and the concave positive and
that's why you can see it's marked in as
a special time here right there at time
six so if you want if you zoom in close
enough right I can't do it on my iPad if
you zoom in close enough you can see
this section of the graph it
is adequately imitated by a straight
line I don't know why I wrote over I
should highlight this so you can see
that looks like a straight line right so
there's no core cavity at that point
which corresponds in this motion
situation to no acceleration either
positive or negative so therefore I can
say I'm the first question when is its
acceleration zero it's after six seconds
so let's write that down
acceleration is zero after six seconds
and then I have to go to the other part
of the question as well right so it then
asks where is it in what direction is it
moving well where is it is a question of
displacement which is on my original
graphs vertical axis so you can see over
there if I if I correspond over to the
left
it's a position four so it's four meters
in what direction is important so it's
four meters to the right of the origin
so we'll write that down acceleration is
zero after six seconds I might put a
full-stop there at that time or in fact
I'm even gonna be lazier and I'm gonna
just borrow the fact that I said this oh
yeah and this time it is I think we said
four meters yeah four meters to the
right of the origin for me is to the
right and in what direction is it moving
well you can think it's moving in the
negative direction that's why it has a
negative gradient at that point is
decreasing which in our scheme means
negative motion is to the left right so
it is moving to the left
four meters to the right and moving to
the left okay fantastic all right